the quarterback position continues to be
the most important on the field
washington general manager martin mayhew
talked to reporters today along with
head coach ron rivera
about the quarterback position even
though they've got fits magic they know
miles say it with me he can be
if it's tragic so they they talked about
the possibility of addressing the
quarterback position in the 2021 draft
here they are
i would say so i i think for me
especially evaluating quarterbacks i
think time spent on the job is
definitely a positive
um so anytime you see guys with limited
time on the job that that is a concern
for me with uh with the quarterback
position and there certainly are more of
those guys this year the quarterback
position is as much as any it's such a
tough one to figure out
and and obviously i agree with what what
martin said and that is time spent as
many snaps as possible getting as much
work as you can that's that helps a lot
because there's a lot of tape to
evaluate
um you can go back as far as you want uh
and see just the growth that's important
as well so yeah
to that point yes i agree exactly what
martin said
i was so committed to making the fitz
tragic reference i made my own fitz
tragic mistake i didn't set up that
sound the way i should have my apologies
they were talking about the difficulties
in scouting quarterbacks in this year's
draft based upon the fact that there
wasn't the same quality of film from
last year particularly with trey lance
who played in one game in 2020 and uh
coming from a lower level of the sport
as well that just complicates the
overall evaluation process so look i
don't know what it means washington has
ryan fitzpatrick so it's not as obvious
they're looking quarterback i don't know
who's going to be left once we get
through the top 10. i don't know if
washington's even going to have a
remotely
plausible opportunity to try to get in
position to get a tray lance but you
have to do the evaluations you have to
be ready for anything the last thing you
want to do
is just
take a guy because he's sliding you
haven't done the evaluation on him what
are you going to do are you going to do
like your cleveland browns did in the
not-so-great film draft day figure out
the day of the draft their evaluation of
a quarterback that they've never even
thought about taking you can't do that
you got to know ahead of time you got to
be ready for everything that's why they
they spend so much time working they're
ready for anything they do their mock
drafts so they can have every
permutation figured out miles of who may
be there when they pick and they know
everything there is to know about all
those guys who could be there when they
pick
unless they decide that they want to
trade up and they want to go get one of
these quarterbacks who may be sliding
you know in the top 10 or whatever it
happens to be i mean you think about
there are a couple teams there that i
think they could maybe trade with
whether it's the broncos that they
decide whatever quarterback it is at
number one is going to be worth it for
them and it's not necessarily going to
be better than drew lockhe maybe
washington goes there maybe washington
goes to number seven overall
with the detroit lions anything is sort
of possible but i think the interesting
thing is when you're talking about guys
and time spent on task you really are
only talking about trey lance because
everybody else who is sort of thought of
as one of these top qb's in this draft
has spent a good amount of time being
the quarterback unless you want to talk
about zach wilson maybe but then again
you know he's going probably number two
overall and i think we all know that but
i'm talking about guys like kyle trask
helmond those guys have spent plenty of
time as a starting qb in college so it's
going to be interesting to see what
washington does there because we know
they have a quarterback of the present
but the quarterback of the future just
isn't on the roster
and you wonder how much they'll be stung
by what happened two years ago with
dwayne haskins does that make them
hesitant to try to make a big move are
they ready to make it work with ryan
fitzpatrick and
kick the can until next year look you're
gonna have to give up a lot to move
you're gonna have to at least be ready
to part ways with your first round pick
next year on top of the one you're
giving up this year so it all depends
upon how much they like a guy and
they're not going to tell us how much
they like a guy but i agree with you any
concern about not having a film would be
an indication that they've taken a close
look at trey lance here's martin mayhew
on the possibility of drafting a
quarterback and how he feels about the
quarterbacks currently on the roster
it's it's something that you're always
looking for
uh if you don't have one as a gm you're
always looking for that i don't think
that process ever stops um and i think
there's a lot of pressure on that
position you know a lot of these guys um
you know have been very very highly
recruited very you know highly thought
of
uh have not faced as much adversity as
they face going to in nfl city and
dealing with the expectations
i think that's certainly part of the
process
um but you know
it's it's
this is a very it's a very very
difficult position to play
i don't think that all the guys that
don't make it
um are not good football players
i think a lot of times has to do with
the circumstances that those guys get
put into
uh that has a lot to do with whether
they they succeed or fail um so
um
again we feel
very uh confident with the group that we
have
like any position if we can upgrade it
we'll try to try to upgrade it but we
feel confident uh and feel good about
the group that we have right now
and as usual the smart general manager
who ultimately says nothing at all keep
all your options open ultimately be able
to say miles that the guy you got is the
guy you wanted whether you trade up
trade down or stay put the guy we get is
the guy we wanted and then we moved
forward putting our football team
together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports